boom
I know this is my son Michael he has two
awards why I'm so young 75th anniversary
to be 7-5 again we are here tonight to
present you tomorrow
hello and speak the thickly
my father who art in movies will have
the pleasure of revealing the last of
the bests in this annual deliverance
from anxiety which is in this envelope
here and here are the nominees for Best
Picture of the year
Chicago Martin Richards producer
gangs of New York Alberto Grimaldi and
Harvey Weinstein producers
the hours Scott Rudin and Robert Fox
producers
the Lord of the Rings the two towers
Miriam Osborn Fran wolves and Peter
Jackson producers
The Pianist Roman Polanski Robert Van
Musa and Alan surd producers
you're supposed to say and the Oscar
goes to and the winner is
Chicago
this is the first
first nomination for Martin Richard
Oh God
you
very long trip mom dad if I'm standing
oh my god
it started with the great Bob Fosse and
an incredible score by candor Neb and
then
Harvey Weinstein came in with Morel
poster and they stood by and they
believed and they they just stayed with
me and Here I am and oh my god my mind
is going it really is going a a cast
that any producer would die for a
director that was sent from heaven a
blessing Rob Marshall
the most incredible unbelievable
creative and productive staff I'm God
Richard Renee hey Catherine John the
world I think right now Bob Fosse yes he
was the first I mention haha and Queen
Latifah and my executive produces my
executive producers my executive
producers please Neil meron Craig zadan
who worked like dogs on this and uh God
I'm forgetting someone I am I oh yes oh
yes I was grand at with I was going to
end it with thank you
I was going to end it with one thing I
couldn't ended without this to my out my
two angels that sit on my shoulder all
the time my dear Mary Lee my dear Mary
Lee and my late partner Robert friar I
bless you all I bless you
you